billy porter is using his voice
for good the emmy and tony award-winning
actor
narrates equal a four-part lgbtq plus
donkey series on hbo max
chronicling the untold events leading up
to the stonewall uprising
and as porter explains the series gave
him a whole new outlook on the fight for
equality
and justice it was really interesting
for me as somebody who knows a lot about
lgbtq history um it was good and nice to
hear
um about stuff i didn't you know there's
a lot of stuff in
in the in the four-part series that i
have not heard about before so
it's always nice to learn something new
a hundred years ago
lesbians and gays could find their fun
together in the
underground world we're talking the
roaring 20s
and the dirty 30s you know prohibition
speakeasies and the like with as
horrible as this
is you know the silver lining is that
everybody
is awake
most people are awake
and if you're not awake now and if you
don't see it for what it is now
you never will you know but all
of the issues have been laid bare
um the biggest issue being that the
system
actually is not broken but the system is
actually doing exactly what
it was built to do from the beginning
um which is to keep people of color
in the subject in subjugation
the fight for lgbtq plus equality is a
fight
for human equality it's battling the
bullies it's bravery over bigotry
it's for black lives all of them and
it's a fight we win
by voting it's time it's time
to make a change and a change for good
um and it's about the people rising up
and making that so
so that's what you're seeing right now
and i think what's interesting about
this series is that you know it's about
that
you know it's about people taking charge
of their lives and rising up and making
sure
that um we live up
to um what our constitution boasts
which is that all men are created equal
all people
are created equal we can't force us into
your boxes anymore we are not going
what do you say
[Applause]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
an exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos